generally speaking they're not made of
expensive materials but a few minutes on
a movie screen can transform props and
clothing into valuable pieces of
Hollywood memorabilia and a collection
going up for auction today is unusual
for the number of famous items it
contains Janet shamlin has the story
[Music]
you have chosen wisely the search for
the Holy Grail captivated fans in the
Blockbuster Indiana Jones and the Last
Crusade and now the Grail can be yours
now that's the cup of a carpenter it's
among more than 400 pieces of movie
memorabilia up for auction today from
some of Hollywood's most epic films it's
pretty impressive it's cool I mean this
is you're sitting in a room where like
it's pretty much a history of Hollywood
Joe maddalena of Heritage auctions says
this collection is one of a kind
remember when Charlie found the golden
ticket in Willy Wonka and the Chocolate
Factory
[Music]
you can buy a ticket used in the 1971
film bidding started at fifteen thousand
dollars
or how about Captain America's vibranium
shield from Avengers end game the
minimum is 50 000 but this Shield should
probably bring 200 000 you know it's
iconic there's Dick Van Dyke's bold
jacket from Mary Poppins
[Music]
and Kate Winslow's dress from Titanic
when Rose rescues Jack about a dozen
were made because of the water if you
buy Kate Winslet's dress from Titanic
what do you do with it don't wear it
so when you have this you know people
display them there are museums that
collect them you know fashion museums
culture museums madalina says the most
expensive item is likely to be the
Wicked Witch's Hourglass from The Wizard
of Oz this is up there with the Maltese
Falcon with the ruby slippers starting
bid four hundred thousand dollars
how much longer you've got to be alive
and
is this the only surviving one I know of
two other copies that are in private
hands it's probably the only one that'll
come up for auction maybe in our
lifetime there's Julie Andrews guitar
from The Sound of Music the first three
notes just happen to be do re me from
Charlton heston's robe in the Ten
Commandments
hold his mighty hand to Ursula andress's
white bikini in the James Bond film Dr
No it's Hollywood history how do you
ensure that these are authentic bikini
from Dr No came directly from Ursula
under as it was hers was made for her
she kept it so it's really the source of
origin you know we're really careful
about where these come from you don't
have to be
the treat to see
memories from our most loved movies are
Priceless these tangible souvenirs
available for a price
for CBS Saturday morning I'm Janet
shamlian in Dallas
I would bid on every one of them if only
I had a good bank account if you could
pick one oh the Chalice either the
Chalice or the dress or guitar from
Sound of Music I just want you Jeff what
would you take the Chalice probably from
Last Crusade is pretty good it'd be hard
not to but the Wizard of Oz memorabilia
oh yeah so is The Shield the Captain
America oh yeah that was cool 200 Grand
it's all good we just don't have the
money